i mean i
can have quite legendary big cheap meals
sometimes i'm worried that i extend it
to a cheap day the whole day so i've
tried to kind of cut that down a little
bit and sometimes if i don't feel like
the cheat meal was enough of a cheat
meal i'll then cheat the second day
which is cheating on cheating which is
just not right
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi guys i'm liam payne and i'll be
answering some fan questions for that
bible here we go
what do you sing in the shower i went
through like a real ed sheeran's like
first album phase a while ago i don't
really sing in the shower all that much
to be honest with you if i do it's
usually to test if my voice is okay it's
just a little ah yeah we'll be fine
today
literally that's what i do sometimes if
i get in the morning i'm like if the air
cons went on a bit long i'm like hmm and
then i try and do a really high note and
then go okay we maybe we might miss that
song
[Laughter]
if you could grab a drink with any other
celebrity dead or alive who would it be
torn between two people here would
either be brad pitt or leonardo dicaprio
i think i think they've just done some
of my favorite films i'd want to talk to
brad pitt about troy and what workouts
he did for that one because he was an
absolute
mammoth leo you only ever really hear
speak in movies so i feel like we don't
know him all that well because i i
couldn't place him outside of a film you
know what i mean like we see little
pictures of him like running down the
street like covering his face with an
umbrella or like with ten hoodies on
like avoiding paparazzi i mean there was
that really funny video of him and jonah
hill right where he runs down the road
and like scares him which i thought was
great um so i think he'd be a lot of fun
which artists did you listen to growing
up um if i went off my first albums i
think i was in quite an emo phase and it
was lincoln park in the end
was that like gray cd cover which i had
which was like a really meaningful i
mean i was like 10 and i was feeling it
i also had eminem which i probably
shouldn't have been listening to at 10.
we had one mp3 player in the house it
was this little red like mp3 thing so
like i would borrow it off my dad
sometimes and i would be so shocked when
i'd hear snoop dogg drop it like it's
hot on my dance player i'm like when are
you listening to this like what point in
the day at the factory are you dropping
it like it's hot but he was big jeff
he's some man
what is your go-to treat meal oh big
dirty cheeseburger or a pizza i mean i
can have quite legendary big cheap meals
for sure but i mean sometimes i'm
worried that i extend it to a cheap day
the whole day so i've had to kind of cut
that down a little bit and sometimes if
i don't feel like the cheat meal was
enough of a cheat meal i'll then cheat
the second day which is cheating on
cheating which is just not right
what's your best party trick
i can do a kazoo without a kazoo
you know what it actually plays a guitar
solo on my album
there's a song called weekend and the
guitar solo is played by me going
through the microphone i swear to god a
lot better than what i just did there
that was terrible who is your current
favorite musical artist um
who am i listening to
just think about what we listened to in
the car yesterday
i really like the new song
randomly enough from justin bieber the
ghost song because it has sort of a
skippy garage beat to it which is like
old school
uk guys just what i used to listen to
when i was like 12.
i thought i was a tough guy who were you
listening to in the car
we were listening to like old school
jungle classics and decline
and there was a guy that was in a van
next to us in the car and he was like we
were playing like an old school garage
song and to the point where he wanted to
know who was in the car listening to it
he like pulled the car out to try and
sneak through the window to see this is
the highlight of my day actually it was
good do you have any weird phobias weird
phobias
um
no watch i don't have crazy wake up i
used to have a weird phobia of spoons
when i was a kid because it was like
punishment in my school that if you were
naughty you would have to wash up the
dirty dishes from the kids and i
couldn't believe the state that some of
these things were going back in so like
i never used them ever again
like it scarred me for life you can see
what i'm saying though like came back
and i was like oh my god like i've been
eating off these things look at them
they're terrible what's your favorite
song of all time you know what because
i've just been feeling it recently
simply read holding back the ears there
is never a moment that that will annoy
you
just set you in straight away
so good
mick hucknell
ah
love it
what are your best party tricks
apart from lighting our own farms
i didn't say i do it i just said that
people do it people do it yeah
someone assists you with that
well
um the night of the premiere i know what
i'll be doing